[Music]
pig farmers are predicting a global
bacon shortage yeah however they say
these shortage can be averted if chris
Christie converts to Islam
crazy story a Manhattan's soccer mom has
pled guilty to running a prostitution
ring a soccer mom prostitution ring yeah
clients of the prostitution ring say
they're gonna miss the post sex juice
box and the ride in her minivan big
names you mrs. Johnson
[Laughter]
that was great sex TLC announced that
honey boo boo is gonna have her own
Halloween special honey boo boo is gonna
have a Halloween special yeah their
neighbors are playing to give them a
scare by dressing up as Child Protective
Services in a a school district in Texas
it's now legal for a female teacher to
spank a male student that's legal this
is due to a new law pushed through by a
group of male students I couldn't
believe this Peter you heard the news
about Pizza Hut uh it's always something
crazy with them yeah you could say that
after any set up too much oh hey what's
going on in Washington Andy oh those
guys are nuts
hey did you hey what's going on in the
news oh it's too crazy for me to pay
attention to
I think we have our new formula down
Pizza Hut has unveiled their newest
pizza I'm not making this up pizza with
a crust made out of cream cheese filled
cones they're calling it the autopsy
lovers Pizza crazy story out of Hong
Kong in Hong Kong a billionaire is
offering 65 million dollars to any man
who can woo and marry his lesbian
daughter yeah meanwhile his daughter is
offering 65 million dollars to anyone
that can explain to her father what a
lesbian is
[Applause]